i've been asked to make predictions for
the year 20 60 or 50 years in the future
and i thought i would focus this video
on things that i feel uh pretty good
about or things that i feel are close to
to to my heart and hopefully things that
things like the khan academy might be
able to bring about so the first big
change i expect in the next 50 years and
actually don't think it'll take 50 years
for it to happen it'll probably happen
fairly quickly over the next 10 years is
that the classroom model fundamentally
changes so classroom
different
and it's going to change from a model
like this and not all classrooms look
like this there are already classrooms
that are exploring different types of
ways for students to interact with each
other and with the professor but still
in most classrooms of the world
especially if you take the introductory
courses at most universities you'll see
something like this you'll see a a
professor lecturing in some way and a
bunch of students sitting in rows taking
notes and then they'll take an exam at
the end of the term
in probably frankly 10 years this is
going to go away completely go away you
won't have people passively sitting in
lecture halls taking notes so we're
going to move from a passive model
a passive taking lectures completely and
this is already happening to a certain
degree completely to an active
active i would call it discovery
discovery and creative model so the
classroom of the future will look
something much more like this in fact
you might not even call it a classroom
you would call it in a room or some type
of project room or something like that
and the general idea is right now all of
these resources are
are spent for people to passively get
get information from a professor when
that is necessary and there will be
times where you want to learn a little
bit of what someone else discovered
about calculus or quantum physics or
anything like that that'll be at your
own time at your own pace and we can
pretend like that's happening to this
gentleman right over there and maybe
he's even able to practice some of those
core skills but a bulk of the time will
be spent doing this we'll be doing
building things creating things
exploring things and it doesn't just
have to be science and technology these
people look like they're building some
type of a robot it could be it could be
a painting a picture or composing a a a
sonata or or choreographing a dance
whatever it might be it's going to be
much more active uh discovery-based and
creative and actually one i think this
is going to happen technologically
because a lot of the stuff that's
happening in this in this fa in this
model right over here can happen can can
can start to happen a little bit more
efficiently through this model so it
frees up time for this but it's also
going to be a social imperative that it
happens if you rewind a few hundred
years
and actually you don't even have to
rewind that far the bulk of society the
bulk of society was kind of involved in
i'll call it physical labor
physical
physical labor you had a smaller
fraction that was involved in mental
labor
so i'll call this mental labor sometimes
white-collar jobs
mental labor something like filling out
your taxes that is mental labor and you
had a very small percentage of society
so this is kind of historically and i'm
even overstating what it is a very small
percentage of society spent in kind of
innovation creativity art things like
that so art
art innovation
true science true pushing the frontiers
of the human experience and human
understanding forward
now as you get more and more technology
technology especially with the
industrial revolution started to
automate a lot of this and it also
cremated the pie bigger and so when you
have a kind of an industrial society
what happened is the necessity for
physical labor went down so you had a
smaller percentage of the population
that needed to do physical labor
the mental labor actually grew
so more people can now be involved in
things like
mental labor and obviously even
automation is handling some of that as
well but you've freed up more people to
do mental labor and you've definitely
freed up a good bit more of resources
and people that can now do the the
frontier pushing the envelope the art
the innovation the creativity
now if we fast forward to the year 2060
i think this is going to become an
extreme form where almost no physical
labor is necessarily required people
might like to do it for exercise
so this part right over here is going to
be very very very small especially in
developed countries and hopefully by
2016 most countries will be developed
even the mental labor is going to be
taken over more and more by automation
so a lot of this is going to be
automated so you're going to need less
people doing traditional mental labor
tasks filling out paperwork
filling out your taxes things like that
and it's going to free up a lot of
wealth and a lot of resources and a lot
of people's hours to do truly artful
creative innovative things and so the
bulk of society i think by 2060 if
things go well
we'll be over here we'll be in this kind
of creative class this is where most
people will sit so it's actually an
imperative that our classrooms one the
tools are are happening to make it
possible to make it feasible but not
only that but it's imperative if society
really is moving in this direction and i
think it is so that we have as many
people as possible that can do this
research and development that can do
truly creative activity
now corollary to this idea that the
classroom will be different that people
will be working self-paced they'll be
spending a lot more time working on
projects is that instead of our
credentials being for the most part seat
time based
so right now our credentials and it's
not 100 seat time but to a large degree
most people use you spend 12 or actually
13 years in k-12 so that's 13 years
and then if you get a college degree
it's expected it's going to be another
four years four years and there are some
people who are able to tweak this skip a
grade here or there but for the most
part the bulk of people do 13 years and
then four years and then what the
variable is is how well you actually
achieved how well you actually
understood your the material so the
variable so this thing is relatively
fixed
this thing is fixed and then the
variable is your level of achievement
is your level of achievement
achievement forgot an e achievement
and this right over here is variable so
some people go through this system with
straight a's they've really understood
everything or hopefully they've
understood everything if they got
straight a's some people have b some
people get c's and that's why we have
something called a grade point average
it shows that variation in achievement
even though everyone is kind of in this
fixed seat time what we're going to
transition to especially once everyone
is learning at their own pace they don't
have to kind of move together lockstep
in these classrooms is you're going to
go to an achievement based
it's going to be an achievement
based model where there are achievements
that you are trying to get to and they
can be multiple things part of the
achievements could be skills like maybe
calculus or or being able to
read music
or being able to
i don't know understand quantum physics
these would all be achievements but you
decide how you will learn
to to master these core concepts so it
won't be based on you have to spend 13
years and then four years going into
debt to do it you could go to a formal
institution to learn some of this stuff
or you could learn however you see fit
you might be able to be an apprentice
with someone and then eventually and
then eventually show that you know
quantum physics very well
and i could imagine these achievements
would be far more rigorous than the
assessments that are being given right
now they could be oral examinations they
could be practical examinations they
could be contingent upon you building or
applying some of this information but
what's interesting about this is now the
seat time the time is variable so now
let me write this the time
is now the variable
you can do this whenever wherever
however long it takes you can even
revisit things when you're 40 or 50
there won't be any artificial stopping
point that you are 22 your college grad
now you will not learn new things
anymore and what's fixed and i won't
call it fixed because you can always get
more and more achievements but the
achievements will be at a high standard
it's a fixed high standard so that if
you get this reading music achievement
you really do know how to read music
which is different than some of the
achievements if i get a c in a calculus
class it's not clear that i actually do
understand calculus in fact it's not
even true necessarily true if i got an a
in a calculus class whether i definitely
understand calculus so fixed high
fixed high standards and i imagine that
the only credentials won't just be these
kind of subject-based credentials the
most important part because remember the
emphasis here is on the creative on the
projects and in creative fields your
real transcript is not your gpa your
real transcript is your portfolio of
projects portfolio of work that you've
done so people will get things like this
to show that they've that they
understand specific domains but the most
important part of the transcript of the
future will be people's achievements
or i should say their projects so you
know maybe i made a robot that can uh
maybe make make toast of some kind maybe
i've maybe i've painted a picture
so here's a picture
maybe i've written a piece of software
that does something interesting so some
software
so what employers and other people will
really care about isn't just your gpa or
how much time you spent in a lecture
hall they'll say show me the stuff that
you have actually built that you've
actually that shows that you are that
you are really in this creative class
that you could start from scratch and
create something new and novel
and i also imagine because we'll be
getting so much data while people are
actually working on working on getting
some of their core skills that you won't
just even have these do you know
calculus do you know quantum physics
you'll also have metrics how hard
working were you how persev
how well did you persevere especially
maybe when you failed first these would
be i think considered to be good things
and on top of that you could start to
measure how how well did you help others
so that could be another achievement
helping
helping others when you virtually tutor
people or physically tutor people they
rate you and they say wow that person
really did help me and we can even look
at the data to see whether you had a
statistically significant impact on
their results
now the next corollary with this
different classroom and this achievement
based learning is i think the role of
the teacher will change dramatically and
i think it'll be in a very powerful way
so the role of the teacher
rather than being a lecturer rather than
being a lecturer and often giving
similar lectures from year to year and
always going at the same pace the
teacher will now be a coach or a mentor
and anyone who's ever seen a great
footballer basketball coach will tell
you that a great coach or mentor is a
very rich a very rich and important role
and so i think that the role of the
teacher will go up will go up
dramatically and it actually won't even
be an isolated profession anymore right
now in a t in a traditional classroom
because it's lecture based you have a
classroom of 20 25 30 students another
classroom of 20 25 30 students and in
each of them you'll have a teacher in
each of them you have a teacher
often at the front of the classroom
running class lecturing in some way
because every student is now working at
their own pace at their own time and the
teachers are now spending most of their
time interacting with students i can
imagine a world where why have these
walls between classrooms why not just
have one larger classroom
now it's 70 75 90 students and all three
teachers
all three teachers work together and so
it becomes
the teachers aren't isolated in their
rooms they're all able to tag team and
play to each other's strengths and the
students will have the benefit instead
of having the benefit of one
one i guess experience base and
knowledge set the students have the
experience base of all of these teachers
and not only that they'll also be
tutoring each other so in this model in
this model it's all going from the
teacher to the student
from the teacher's students here it's
going from teachers to multiple students
teachers from multiple students and from
students to students and maybe even
students to teachers so it's going from
it's it's going from peer-to-peer and
multiple
teachers to multiple peers and i think
in this type of a model because the
teacher is going to become that much
more valuable because now it is all
interactive there is no more passive
lecture there is no giving the same
lecture every year i think that the the
the profession of teaching will become
even more prestigious so my big
and i'm saying 2060 but i think this is
going to happen over the next 10 to 15
years so i think by 2020 or 2025 you're
going to have the teaching profession is
going to be go become at parity with
professions like medicine or law or
engineering in terms of how much a
teacher can make and how they are valued
by society so i predict in this reality
teachers based on today's money if
you're inflation adjusted are going to
make hundred fifty thousand to two
hundred thousand per year and for any of
those who say hey where's the money for
a hundred fifty thousand to two hundred
thousand dollars per year you just
should realize that right now most
states even if you just focus on public
schools are spending on the order of ten
thousand dollars a student
they're spending ten thousand dollars
per student and if you had a 25 to one
student-to-teacher ratio that means that
you have
so
if you multiply it by 25 students that
means you have 250 thousand two hundred
fifty thousand dollars for the teacher
and the facilities and any other
technology
and uh i'm all all i'm arguing for is
that the master teachers the ones that
are really pushing the envelope here
should get a bulk of these resources as
opposed to layers of bureaucracy and
whatever else
now the last prediction i'll make
related to education right over here and
it's related to all of this is because
because the actual cost of delivering a
lot of the core material a lot of the
core practice over here is going to go
close to zero because you'll really just
need an internet connection and and
maybe your peers who are also learning
alongside of you and it'll become even
better if you have a a really amazing
experienced professional teacher with
you but my the the fourth part of it is
i believe we're going to get to a 99
global literacy rate and we're already
close to this in much of the developed
world but in the developing world it's
significantly below this and obviously
you can imagine if we do get to this
type of literacy rate what that means
for
health care what that means for
population what that means for economic
growth what that means for wars i think
this is a it's a very very very positive
thing and coinciding with this idea that
students around the world are able to
get access to a world-class education
that it's like having clean drinking
water or electricity
i think you start getting closer to a
global meritocracy
where that student who right now she
might just be the daughter of of beggars
in some part of the developed world but
because she has access to this material
and she can develop herself and and
people will know how she's developing
herself because all of the data is being
logged we can say wow that she has the
potential to really be one of the
leaders in this creative class she has a
potential to to to find the cure for
cancer or find a a new way of doing x y
or z and so you really can give these
students all over the world
all over the world the opportunities
that they that they really should have
and hopefully there will be a ton of
opportunities because the pie will have
gotten so much bigger that we can
support a lot of these creative
endeavors